foreign
you
the senate will convene as a court of
impeachment
and the chaplain dr barry black will
lead the senate in prayer
let us pray mighty god
unsurpassed in both power and
understanding we worship
you lord
when there is nowhere else to turn
we lift our eyes to you
as again this senate chamber
becomes a court and our senators
become jurors guide these lawmakers
with your wisdom mercy
and grace lord infuse
them with a spirit of non-partisan
patriotism unite them
in their efforts to do what
is best for america
as they depend on your providence
and power may they make
choices that will be for
your greater glory
we pray in your sovereign name
amen amen
join me in the pledge of allegiance
and um senators will you please be
seated
and if there is no objection the journal
proceedings of the trial are approved
today
and asked the sergeant-arms to make the
proclamation
hear ye hear ye hear ye all persons are
commanded to keep silence
on pain of imprisonment while the senate
of the united states
is sitting for the trial of the article
of impeachment
exhibited by the house of
representatives against donald john
trump
former president of the united states
uh mr president the majority leaders
recognized for the information of all
senators will plan to take short breaks
approximately every two hours and a
longer dinner break
around 5 p.m
now pursuant to the provisions of senate
resolution 47
the council for the former president has
16 hours
to make the presentation of their case
and the senate will hear the council now
begin the presentation of the case for
the former president
go ahead
good afternoon senators
mr president
the article of impeachment now before
the senate
is an unjust and blatantly
unconstitutional
act of political vengeance this
appalling abuse of the constitution
only further divides our nation when we
should be trying to come together
around shared priorities
like ever like every other politically
motivated witch-hunt
the left has engaged in over the past
four years
this impeachment is completely divorced
from the facts
the evidence and the interests of the
american people
the senate should promptly and
decisively
vote to reject it no thinking person
could seriously believe that the
president's
january 6th speech on the ellipse
was in any way an incitement to violence
or insurrection the suggestion
is patently absurd on its face
nothing in the text could ever be
construed
as encouraging condoning
or enticing unlawful activity
of any kind
far from promoting insurrection against
the united states
the president's remarks explicitly
encouraged
those in attendance to exercise their
rights
peacefully and patriotically
peaceful and patriotic protest is the
very antithesis
of a violent assault on the nation's
capital
the house impeachment article
slanderously alleges that the president
intended for the crowd at the ellipse to
quote interfere with the joint sessions
solemn constitutional duty to certify
the results of the 2020 presidential
election
this is manifestly disproven by the
plain text of the remarks
the president devoted nearly his entire
speech to an extended discussion of how
legislators should vote on the question
at hand
instead of expressing a desire that the
joint session be prevented
from conducting its business the entire
premise of his remarks
was that the democratic process would
and should play out according to the
letter of the law
including both the constitution and the
electoral count
act in the conclusion of his remarks he
then laid out a series of legislative
steps
that should be taken to improve
democratic
accountability going forward
such as passing universal voter id
legislation
banning ballot harvesting requiring
proof of citizen citizenship to vote
and turning out strong in the next
primaries
not only presidents these are not the
words of someone
inciting a violent insurrection
not only president trump's speech on
january
6 but indeed his entire challenge to the
election
results was squarely focused on how the
proper civic
process could address any concerns
through the established
legal and constitutional system the
president
brought his case before state and
federal courts
the u.s supreme court the state
legislatures
the electoral college and ultimately the
u.s congress
in the past numerous other candidates
for president have used many of the same
processes to pursue their own election
challenges
as recently as 2016
the clinton campaign brought multiple
post-election court cases
demanded recounts and ridiculously
declared
the election stolen by russia
many democrats even attempted to
persuade the electoral college delegates
to overturn
the 2016 results house manager raskin
objected to the certification of
president trump's victory
four years ago along with many of his
colleagues
you'll remember it was joe biden who had
to gavel them down
i have an objection because 10 of the 29
electoral votes cast by florida were
cast by electors not lawfully certified
i object to the votes from the state of
wisconsin which would not should not be
legally sentenced to no
mr president i object to the certificate
from the state of georgia on the grounds
that the electoral vote
no debate there's no debate did i object
to a certificate
uh from the state of north carolina i
object to the 15 votes from the state of
north carolina um
i object i object to the certificate
from the state of alabama
the electors were not lawfully certified
is it signed by a senator
not as of yes mr president in that case
the objection cannot be
entertained the objection cannot be
entertained counting is
please come to
the united states code prohibits debate
in the joint session
i do not wish to debate i wish to ask is
there one united states senator
who will join me in this letter there is
no debate
there's no debate the gentlewoman will
suspend
in 2000 the dispute over the outcome was
taken all the way to the supreme court
which ultimately rendered a decision
to litigate questions of election
integrity within the
system is not incitement to resurrection
it is the democratic system working as
the founders
and lawmakers have designed
to claim that the president in any way
wished
desired or encouraged lawless or violent
behavior
is a preposterous and monstrous lie
in fact the first two messages the
president sent
via twitter once the incursion of the
capital began where
stay peaceful and no violence because we
are the party
of law and order
the gathering on january 6th was
supposed to be a peaceful event
make no mistake about that and the
overwhelming majority
of those in attendance remained peaceful
as everyone knows the president had
spoken at hundreds of large rallies
across the country over the past five
years
there had never been any mob like uridis
behaviors and in fact
a significant portion of each event was
devoted
to celebrating the rule of law
protecting our constitution
and honoring the men and women of law
enforcement
contrast the president's repeated
condemnations of violence
with the rhetoric from his opponents i
am your president
of law and order and an ally of all
peaceful protesters the vast majority of
the protesting
of peace republicans stand for
law and order and we stand for justice i
just don't even know why there aren't
uprisings all over the country maybe
there will be
my administration will always stand
against violence
mayhem and disorder there needs to be
unrest in the streets for as long as
there is unrest in our lives
i stand with the heroes of law
enforcement
anymore we will never defund our police
together we will ensure that america is
a nation of law
and order we're in high school i'd take
you behind the gym and beat the hell out
of them
i think you need to go back and then
punch him in the face feel like punching
him
we just want law and order everybody
wants that i want to tell you
i want to tell you kavanaugh you have
released the whirlwind
and you will pay the pride we want law
and order we have to have law and order
show me where it says that protests are
supposed to be polite and peaceful
we believe in safe streets secure
communities and we believe in law
and order
tragically as we know now
the january on january 6 6
a small group who came to engage in
violent and menacing behavior
hijacked the event for their own
purposes
according to publicly available
reporting it is apparent that extremists
of various different stripes and
political persuasions
pre-planned and premeditated
an attack on the capital
one of the first people arrested was the
leader of antifa
sadly he was also among the first to be
released
from the beginning the president has
been clear
the criminals who infiltrated the
capital must be punished to the fullest
extent of the law
they should be imprisoned for as long as
the law allows
the fact that the attacks were
apparently premeditated
as alleged by the house managers
demonstrates the ludicrousness of the
incitement allegation
against the president
you can't incite what was already going
to happen
law enforcement officers at the scene
conducted themselves heroically
and courageously and our country owes
them an eternal debt
but there must be a discussion of the
decision by political leadership
regarding forced posture and security
in advance of the event as many will
recall
last summer the white house was faced
with violent
violent riders night after night
they repeatedly attacked secret service
officers and at one point
pierced a security wall culminating
in the clearing of lafayette square
since that time there has been a
sustained
negative narrative in the media
regarding the necessity of those
security measures on that night even
though
they certainly prevented many calamities
from occurring
in the wake of the capital attack it
must be investigated whether the proper
force
posture was not initiated due to
to the political pressure stemming from
the events at lafayette square
consider this on january 5th the mayor
of the district of columbia
explicitly discouraged the national
guard and federal authorities
from doing more to protect the capital
saying
and i quote the district of columbia is
not requesting
other federal law enforcement personnel
and discourages any additional
deployment
this sham impeachment also poses a
serious threat to freedom of speech for
political leaders
of both parties at every level of
government
the senate should be extremely careful
about the president
the precedent this case will set
consider the language that the house
impeachment article
alleges to constitute incitement
if you don't fight like hell you're not
going to have a country anymore
this is ordinary political rhetoric that
is virtually
indistinguishable from the language that
has been used
by people across the political spectrum
for
hundreds of years
countless politicians have spoken of
fighting for our principles
joe biden's campaign slogan was battle
for the soul of america
no human being seriously believes that
the use of such
metaphorical terminology is incitement
to political violence
while the president did not engage in
any language of incitement
there are numerous officials in
washington who have indeed used
profoundly
reckless dangerous and inflammatory
rhetoric in recent years
the entire democratic party and national
news media
spent the last four years repeating
without any evidence that the 2016
election had been hacked
and falsely and absurdly claimed
the president of the united states was a
russian spy
speaker pelosi herself said that the
2016 election was hijacked
and that congress has a duty to protect
our democracy
she also called the president an
imposter and a traitor
and recently referred to her colleagues
in the house
as the enemy within
moreover many democrat politicians
endorsed and encouraged
the riots that destroyed vast swaths of
american cities
last summer when violent
left-wing anarchists conducted a
sustained
assault on a federal courthouse in
portland oregon
speaker pelosi did not call it an
insurrection
instead she called the federal law
enforcement
officers protecting the building
stormtroopers
when violent mobs destroyed public
property she said
people will do what they do the attorney
general of the state of massachusetts
stated
yes america is burning
but that's how forests grow
representative anya presley declared
there needs to be unrest in the streets
for as long as there is
is unrest in our lives the current vice
president of the united states kamala
harris urged supporters
to donate to a fund that bailed out
violent rioters and
arsonists out of jail
one of those was released and went out
and committed another crime
assault he beat the bejesus out of
somebody
she said of the violent demonstrations
everyone beware they're not going to
stop before
election day in november and they're not
going to stop
after election day they're not going to
let up
and they should not
such rhetoric continued even as hundreds
of police officers across the nation
were subjected to violent assaults
at the hands of angry mobs
a man claiming to be inspired by the
junior senator
from vermont came down here to
washington dc to watch a softball game
and kill as many senators and
congressmen
as he could it cannot be forgotten that
president trump did not blame the junior
senator
the senior senator from maine has had
her house surrounded
by angry mobs of protesters
when that happened and unnerved her
one of the house managers i forget which
one tweeted
crimea river
under the standards of the house
impeachment article
each of these individuals should be
retroactively censored
expelled punished or impeached
for inciting violence by their
supporters
unlike the left president trump has been
entirely
consistent in his opposition to mob
violence
he opposes it in all forms in all places
just as he's been consistent that the
national guard should be deployed to
protect american communities
wherever protection is needed
for democrats they have clearly
demonstrated that their opposition to
mobs
and their view of using the national
guard
depends upon the mob's political views
not only is this impeachment case
preposterously wrong
on the facts no matter how much heat
and emotion is injected by the political
opposition
it is also plainly unconstitutional
in effect congress would be claiming
that
the right to disqualify a private
citizen no longer a government official
from running for public office this
would transform the solemn
impeachment process into a mechanism for
asserting congressional control
over which private citizens are
and are not allowed to run for president
in short this unprecedented effort is
not about
democrats opposing political violence
is about democrats trying to disqualify
their political
opposition it is constitutional
cancel culture
history will will record this shameful
effort as a deliberate attempt by the
democrat party to smear
censor and cancel not just
president trump but the 75 million
americans who voted for him
now is not the time for such a campaign
of retribution
it is the time for unity
and healing and focusing on the
interests of the nation as a whole
we should all be seeking to cool
temperatures
calm passions rise above
partisan lines
the senate should reject this divisive
and unconstitutional effort and allow
the nation to move forward
over the next over the course the next
three hours or so
you will hear next from mr shone who's
going to
talk about due process and a couple
other points you'll
be interested to hear i'll return with
the now
within an analysis of why the first
amendment must be
properly applied here and
then mr castro will discuss the law as
it applies
to the speech of january 6th
and then we'll be pleased to answer your
questions thank you
might be it
mr president mr shone leaders
senators throughout the course of today
my colleagues and i will explain in some
detail the simple fact that president
trump did not incite the horrific
terrible riots of january 6th
will demonstrate that to the contrary
the violence and looting
goes against the law and order message
he conveyed to every citizen of the
united states
throughout his presidency including
on january 6th first though
we would like to discuss the hatred the
vitriol
the political opportunism that has
brought us here today
the hatred that the house managers and
others on the left have for president
trump
has driven them to skip the basic
elements of due process
and fairness and to russian impeachment
through the house claiming
quote urgency close quotes but the house
waited to deliver the articles to the
senate for almost two weeks
only after democrats had secured control
over the senate
in fact contrary to their claim that the
only reason
they held it was because senator
mcconnell wouldn't accept the article
representative clyburn made clear that
they had considered holding the articles
for over a hundred days to provide
president biden with a clear pathway
to implement his agenda
our constitution and any basic sense of
fairness
require that every legal process with
significant consequences for a person's
life
including impeachment requires due
process
under the law which includes fact
finding and the establishment of a
legitimate
evidentiary record with an appropriate
foundation even last year's impeachment
followed committee hearings and months
of examination
and investigation by the house
here president trump and his counsel
were given no opportunity to review
evidence
or question its propriety the rush to
judgment
for a snap impeachment in this case was
just one example
of the denial of due process another
perhaps even more
vitally significant example
was the denial of any opportunity ever
to test the integrity of the evidence
offered against donald j
trump in a proceeding seeking to bar him
from ever holding public office again
and that seeks to disenfranchise some 75
million
voters american voters
on wednesday this week countless news
outlets repeated
the democrat talking point about the
power of
never be see never before seen footage
let me ask you this why was this footage
never seen
before shouldn't the subject of an
impeachment trial this impeachment trial
president trump have the right to see
the so-called new evidence against him
more importantly the riot and the attack
on this very building
was a major event that shocked and
impacted all americans
shouldn't the american people have seen
this footage as soon as it was available
for what possible reason do the house
managers withhold it
from the american people and president
trump's lawyers
for political gain how did they get it
how are they the ones releasing it it is
evidence in hundreds of pending criminal
cases against the rioters
why was it not released through law
enforcement or the department of justice
is it the result of a rushed snap
impeachment
for political gain without due process
house manager raskin told us all
yesterday that your job as
jurors in this case is a fact intensive
job
but of course as several of the house
managers have told you
we still don't have the facts speaker
pelosi yourself
on february 2nd called for a 911 style
commission
to investigate the events of january 6th
speaker pelosi says that the commission
is needed
to determine the causes of the events
she says it herself if an inquiry of
that magnitude is needed
to determine the causes of the riot
and it may very well be then how can
these same democrats have the certainty
needed
to bring articles of impeachment and
blame the riots on president trump
they don't the house managers facing a
significant lack of evidence
turned off into press reports and rumors
during these proceedings
claims that would never meet the
evidentiary standards of any court
in fact they even relied on the words of
andrew feinberg
a reporter who recently worked for
sputnik the russian propaganda outlet
you saw it posted by the way the report
they cited was completely refuted
the frequency with which house managers
relied on unproven media reports shocked
me
as i sat in this chamber and listened to
this
and there's a lot that we don't know yet
about what happened that day
according to those around him at the
time reportedly responded
trump reportedly reports across all
major media outlets
major news networks including fox news
reported
reported reportedly summoned reportedly
reportedly not
accidental according to reports
president trump was reportedly
who reportedly spoke to the guard and
was widely reported
media reports according to reports
reported
reportedly
as any trial lawyer will tell you
reportedly
is a euphemism for i have no real
evidence
reportedly is not the standard in any
american setting
in which any semblance of due process
is afforded and accused reportedly
isn't even here is some circumstantial
evidence
it is exactly as reliable as i googled
this for you
and if you're worried you might ever be
tried based on
this type of evidence don't be
you get more due process than this when
you fight a parking ticket
one reason due process is so important
with respect to evidence offered against
an accused
is that it requires an opportunity to
test the integrity
the credibility the reliability
of the evidence here of course former
president trump was completely denied
any such opportunity and it turns out
there is significant reason to doubt the
evidence
the house managers have put before us
let me say this
clearly we have reason to believe
the house managers manipulated evidence
and selectively edited
footage if they did and this were a
court of law
they would face sanctions from the judge
i don't raise this issue lightly
rather it is a product of what we have
found in just the limited time
we have had since we first saw the
evidence here
with you this week
we have reason to believe that the house
managers created false representations
of tweets
and the lack of due process means there
was no opportunity
to review or verify the accuracy
consider these facts the house managers
proud of their work on the snap
impeachment stage numerous photo shoots
of their preparations
in one of those manager raskin is seen
here at his desk
reviewing two tweets side by side
the image on his screen claims to show
that president trump had retweeted one
of those tweets
now members of the senate let's look
closely at this screen
because obviously manager raskin
considered it
important enough that he invited the new
york times to watch him watching it
now what's wrong with this image
actually
there are three things very wrong with
it look at the date on the very bottom
of the screen
on manager raskin's computer screen when
we zoom into the picture
the date that appears is january 3rd
2020 not
2021 why is that date wrong
because this is not a real screenshot
that he's working with this is a
recreation of a tweet
and you got the date wrong when you
manufactured this graphic
you did not disclose that this is a
manufactured graphic and not a real
screenshot of a tweet
that to be fair the house managers
caught this error before showing the
image on the senate floor
so you never saw it when it was
presented to you
but that's not all they didn't fix this
one
look at the blue check mark next to the
twitter username of the account
retweeted
by the president it indicates that this
is a
verified account given the blue check by
twitter to indicate it is run by a
public figure
the problem the user's real account is
not verified and has no blue check mark
as you can see were you trying to make
your account seem more significant
or were you just sloppy if we had due
process of law in this case
we would know the truth but that's not
all
that's wrong with this one tweet
house manager swalwell showed you this
tweet this week and he emphasized
that this tweet reflected a call to arms
he told you repeatedly that this was a
promise
to call in the cavalry for january 6th
he expressly led you to believe that
president trump's supporter
believed that the president wanted armed
supporters
at the january 6th speech paramilitary
groups
the cavalry ready for physical combat
the problem is the actual text is
exactly the opposite
the tweeter promised to bring the
calvary
a public display of christ's crucifixion
a central symbol of her christian faith
with her to the president's speech a
symbol of faith
love and peace they just never want to
seem to read the text
and believe what the text means you'll
see this reported in the media
last evening also words matter
they told you but they selectively
edited the president's words
over and over again they manipulated
video
time shifting clips and made it appear
the president's words
were playing to a crowd when they
weren't
let's take a look after this
we're going to walk down and i'll be
there with you we're going to walk down
[Applause]
we're going to walk down to the one you
want but i think right here we're going
to walk down
to the capitol
and we're going to cheer on our brave
senators and congressmen and women
and we're probably not going to be
cheering so much for
some of them because you'll never
take back our country with weakness you
have to show strength and you have to be
strong
we have come to demand that congress do
the right thing
and only count the electors who have
been lawfully
slated lawfully slated
i know that everyone here will soon be
marching over to the capitol building
to peacefully and patriotically make
your voices heard
and we are going to walk down to the
capitol they showed you that part
why are we walking to the capitol will
they cut that off
to cheer on some members of congress and
not others peacefully
and patriotically the supreme court
ruled in brandenburg that there's a very
clear standard for incitement
in short to paraphrase whether the
speech was intended to provoke imminent
lawless action
and was it likely to do so go to the
capitol
and cheer on some members of congress
but not others
they know it doesn't meet the standard
for incitement
so they edited it down
we heard a lot this week about fight
like hell
but they cut off the video before they
showed you the president's
optimistic patriotic words that followed
immediately after we fight like hell
and if you don't fight like hell you're
not going to have a country anymore
our exciting adventures and boldest
endeavors
have not yet begun my fellow americans
for our movement
for our children and for our beloved
country
and i say this despite all that's
happened
the best is yet to come
there's that famous quote like one of
the house managers said
a lie will travel halfway around the
world before the truth
has a chance to put its shoes on well
this lie traveled around the world a few
times made its way into the biden
campaign talking points
and ended up on the senate floor the
charlottesville lie
very fine people on both sides except
that isn't all he said
and they knew it then and they know it
now watch this
but you also had people that were
very fine people on both sides you had
people in that group excuse me
excuse me i saw the same pictures as you
did you had people
in that group that were there to protest
the taking down of
to them a very very important statue
and the renaming of a park from robert e
lee to another name
george washington was a slave owner was
george washington a slave owner
so will george washington now lose his
status are we going to take down
excuse me are we going to take down are
we going to take down statues to george
how about thomas jefferson what do you
think of thomas jefferson you like him
okay good are we going to take down the
statue because he was a major slave
owner
now we're going to take down his statue
so you know what
it's fine you're changing history you're
changing culture
and you had people and i'm not talking
about the neo-nazis and the white
nationalists
because they should be condemned totally
but you had many people in that group
other than neo-nazis and white
nationalists okay
and the press has treated them
absolutely unfairly
now in the other group also you had some
fine people but you also had trouble
makers
and you see them come with uh with the
black outfits
and with the helmets and with the
baseball bats
you gotta you had a lot of bad you had a
lot of bad people in the other group too
unfairly i'm sorry i just understand
what you were saying you were saying the
press has treated white nationalists
unfairly
understand yourself there were people in
that rally and i looked the night before
if you look there were people
protesting very quietly the
taking down of the statue of robert
italy
i'm sure in that group there were some
bad ones the following day it looked
like they had some
rough bad people neo-nazis
uh white nationalists whatever you want
to call them but you had a lot of people
in that group that were there to
innocently protest
and very legally protest because you
know i don't know if you know
they had a permit the other group didn't
have a permit
so i only tell you this there are two
sides to a story
i thought what took place was a horrible
moment
for our country a horrible moment but
there are two sides in the country does
anybody have a final
does anybody have you have an
infrastructure
this might be today the first time the
news networks played those full remarks
in their context and how many times have
you heard that president trump
has never denounced white supremacists
now you and america know the truth
here's another example
one of the house managers made much of
the president's supposedly ominous words
of
you have to get your people to fight but
you knew what the president really meant
he meant that the crowd should demand
action from members of congress
and support primary challenges to those
who don't
do what he considered to be right
support primary
challenges not violent action i know
what he meant
because i watched the full video and so
did the house managers
but they manipulated his words you will
see
where they stopped it and to give it a
very different meaning
from the meaning it has in full context
let's watch
you have to get your people
to fight he told them
you have to get your people to fight and
if they don't fight we have to primary
the hell out of the ones that don't
fight
we primary them we're gonna we're gonna
let you know who they are
i can already tell you frankly
the people who need to fight are members
of congress
why do we have to skip the necessary due
diligence and due process of law
and any that any legal proceeding should
have it couldn't have been the urgency
to get president trump out of office
house democrats held the articles until
he was no longer president
mooting their case hatred animosity
division political gain
and let's face it for house democrats
president trump is the best enemy to
attack
i want to say this for donald trump who
i may well be voting to impeach
donald trump has already done a number
of things which legitimately raised the
question of impeachment
i don't respect this president and i
will fight
every day until he is impeached
that is growls to start impeachment
proceedings those are grounds to start
impeachment those are grounds to start
impeachment proceedings yes
i think that's grounds to start
impeachment proceeding i rise today mr
speaker
to call for the impeachment
of the president of the united states of
america
i continue to say mpgm
and page 45 and page 45.
so we're calling upon the house to begin
impeachment hearings immediately
on the impeachment donald trump would
you vote yes or no i would vote yes
i would vote i would vote because we're
gonna go in there we're gonna impeach
the mother
but the fact is i introduced articles of
impeachment
in july of 2017. if we don't impeach
this president
he will get re-elected my host requires
me to be for impeachment
have an impeachment hearings he needs to
scarlet eye on his chest
the representatives should begin
impeachment proceedings against this
president
it is time to bring impeachment charges
against him
bring impeachment charges my personal
view is that uh he richly deserves
impeachment i'm here
at an impeachment rally and we are ready
to impeach bob
well we can impeach him every day of the
week for anything he does
that same hatred and anger has led house
managers to ignore their own words and
actions
and set a dangerous double standard
the house manager spoke about rhetoric
about a constant drum beat of heated
language
well as i'm sure everyone ex watching
expected
we need to show you some of their own
words
i i i just don't even know why there
aren't uprisings all over the country
maybe there will be
there needs to be unrest in the streets
for as long as there's unrest in our
lives
you gotta be ready to throw a punch you
have to be ready to throw a punch
donald trump i think you need to go back
and punch him in the face
that i thought he should have punched
him in the face i feel like punching him
i'd like to take him behind the gym if i
were in high school we were in high
school i'd take you behind the gym and
beat the hell out of him
no i wish we're in high school i could
take him behind the gym i will go
and take trump out tonight take him out
now
when was the last time an actor
assassinated a president
they're still going to have to go out
and put a bullet in donald trump show me
where it says that protests are supposed
to be polite
and peaceful
[Music]
i have thought an awful lot about
blowing up the white house
please get up in the face of some
congress people
people will do what they do i want to
tell you for such
i want to tell you kavanaugh you have
released the whirlwind
and you will pay the price we're gonna
go in there we're gonna
this is just a warning to you trumpers
be careful
walk lightly and for those of you
who are soldiers make them pay
if you had to be stuck in an elevator
with either president trump mike pence
or jeff sessions who would it be
does one of us have to come out alive
[Laughter]
and there's more i promise to fight
every single day one i i'm a fighter and
i'm
relentless but i'm a fighter and i'm
relentless a fighter and i'm relentless
i will fight like hell but the way i see
it now is that we pick ourselves up and
we fight back
that's what i think it's all about we
stand up and we
fight back we do not back down we do not
compromise
not today not tomorrow not ever
you can either lie down you can you can
whimper you can
pull up in a ball you can decide to move
to canada or you can stand your ground
and fight back and and that's what it's
about
we do fight back but we are going to
fight back we are not
turning this country over to what
donald trump has sold we are just not
look
people are upset and they're right to be
upset now we can whimper
we can whine or we can fight back me
i'm here to fight back
[Applause]
i'm here to fight back because we
will not forget we do not want to forget
we will use that vision to make sure
that we fight harder we fight
tougher and we fight more passionately
for than ever we still have a fight on
our hands
fight hard for the changes americans are
demanding
get in the fight to winning the fight
fight fighting he's fighting
he is every tool possible to fight for
this change
we'll fight we'll fight to fight
fighting hard
serious about fighting and fight we've
got to get on our front foot and fight
back problems we call them out and we
fight back i'm in this fight i am
fighting i am fighting dead
in this fight get in
this fight get in this fight
and fighting we all need to be in the
fight we all need to
stay in the fight we stay in this fight
we fought back
we fought back i am not afraid of a
fight
i am in this fight all the way
you don't get what you don't fight for
our
fight our fight we are in this
fight for our lives this is the fight
of our lives but we are going to make
sure that this fight does not end
tonight
this is a fight
for our lives the lives of our friends
and family members and neighbors
it is a fight fight and it is a fight
that we're gonna
work to make sure continues it's a
fight it is a fight it
is a fight and that's what this fight is
for
well i'm wired to fight anyone who isn't
doing their job for us
i'm jon tester and you're damn right i
approve this message
and i'll have lots of fights ahead of us
and i'm ready to stand up
and keep fighting we have to fight we're
going to fight we're going to fight we
need to fight fight fight and we need to
fight
we're gonna fight we got a few more
fights i'm gonna
take the privilege of a few more fights
and we have the biggest fight of all
i will never stop fighting i will fight
like hell
to fight back against anyone we need to
say loud and clear
that we are ready to fight it's a bare
knuckles fight
now they're going to have to actually
fight back
against people the fight has to be
conducted it's so important that we need
to fight
fight that fight we have been fighting i
was fighting very hard
time is of the essence both in terms of
the fight i think we should be fighting
well i i really believe we need to fight
we're simply not going to take this line
down
we're going to keep fighting so i'm
telling all my colleagues
this is the fight of our life whose side
are you on who are you fighting for
they're fighting for i'm fighting we're
both fighting we will fight back we're
not going to just take this lined up
i'm just going to keep the fight up what
we have to do right now is fight as hard
as we can
we have to rise up and and fight back
and so we're going to fight and we're
going to continue to fight
i am going to be fighting i like hell
keep fighting
fighting fighting or we kept fighting
and we did so we're going to keep
fighting
we have to be fighting every every
single day we have to fight back
and we have no choice but to do that i
think we're doing the right thing to do
that
fighting and i'm fighting well our job
right now is to fight
it's really important i'm going to keep
fighting i'm asking for the support of
people across the country to fight back
and you got to be
fierce in fighting keep fighting brown
have been fighting
i've told president biden i will fight
like mad
i'll tell you what now more than ever we
have to fight like hell
we have these battles on the floor of
the senate i'm going to go down
and battle and uh and i'm going to be
down there on the floor
but we democrats are fighting as hard as
we can democrats are fighting as hard as
we can
credit in any way but we're fighting
back what we've got to do
is fight in congress fight in the courts
fight in the streets fight online fight
at the ballot box
fighting and pushing around the clock
fighting continue to be brave
and be strong and keep fighting we
getting people engaged in the fight
we're fighting we've got to keep
fighting and keep focused
continue to fight fight this is going to
be a fight we'll also fight him and
challenge him in every way that we can
in the congress in the courts and in the
streets to continue
fighting we each have an important role
to play
in fighting in this fight like so many
before it
it has been a fight the american people
are going to have to fight
and about the importance of fighting i
will always fight
fighting but we always
must fight joe biden has a deep
deep-seated commitment to fight and to
fight and about the importance of
fighting we always
must fight to fight to fight and to
fight as our willingness
to fight continue the fight as joe biden
says to fight
it's about fighting of what we're
fighting for we will tell them about
what we did
to fight really about a fight but truly
i do believe that we're in a fight
i believe that we are in a fight i
believe we are in a fight i believe
we are in a fight so there's a fight in
front of us
a fight for all of these things and so
we're prepared to fight for that we know
how to fight
our ongoing fight a fight
we know how to fight we
like a good fight we were born
out of a fight this is what is our fight
right now there's the fight
there's the fight there's the fight and
then there's the fight to defend
back in the fight our mission is to
fight that is the guiding purpose of
house democrats
fighting he has never forgotten who he
is fighting for
march and fought and we just have to
fight but this is
a fight for our country fighting the
health crisis of covet
i led the fight and continue to fight
never
never never give up this fight
i am a citizen fighting for it
means not only fighting a leader who
fought for progressive change as a
lawyer who fought for people his whole
life
as well as other fight scenes and i'm
proud that uh to have
tim in this fight with me and above all
it's time for america to get
back up and once again fight
we will fight when we must fight
what kind of america are we fighting for
we've been fighting so we need to fight
but we also need to fight
fight for an america i am going to wake
up
every day and fight hard i have been
fighting we're gonna fight we are gonna
fight we're gonna fight we're gonna
fight and i will fight we're in the
fight of our lives
right now we fight like hell to fight to
fight fight against the trump
administration democrats are standing up
to fight
we're in this fight in a serious way
it's your fight we're eager to take on
this fight get
in this fight and we'll fight it out i
have taken on the fight
as representatives for the people as
legislators here in the halls of
congress
our job is to fight who has led us in
this fight is to fight for this
this fight and every day i'm in the
united states senate
i will fight one of the things we do is
fight should fight
um because my constituents send me here
each and every day
to fight we have been fighting this
fight and we need to be side by side so
we can succeed
and so i hope that you will all join us
in our fight
and if we fight and as the next governor
of georgia i will never stop
fighting we can show the old guard
something new and we can fight
my fight those fights need to fight to
fight an administration requiring us to
fight and fight we will
their fight in their fight in their
fight the fight
is a fight and so when we fight the
fight that we are
in when we are fighting this fight we
fight this fight the strength of who we
are is we will
fight and we will fight we will fight
the fight we will fight we
are in a fight the fight fight fight
fight
it is a fight as a fight and it is a
fight born
out of patriotism this is a fight
fighting
i say fight on fight on fight on
fight on i'm here to say one more time
in publicly
this is not a fight i wanted to take on
but this is the fight
in front of a snail every single one of
you
and every one of you that's okay
you didn't do anything wrong it's a word
people use
but please stop the hypocrisy and did
you tone down the rhetoric last summer
when all of this was happening did you
condemn the rioters
or did you stand with nancy pelosi who
said
people are going to do what they're
going to do
this is a movement i'm telling you
they're not going to stop
and and everyone beware because they're
not going to stop it
they're not going to stop before
election day in november and they're not
going to stop acting
please show me where it says that
protests are supposed to be polite
and peaceful i just don't even know why
there aren't uprisings all over the
country maybe there will be
it was a violent night they shot and
killed david in cold blood
destroying property which can be
replaced is not
violent this is an apartment complex on
fire and it just collapsed their
building just
these people did this for no reason
this is just a snapshot of some of the
damage that people will be waking up
going up i believe
i'm proud of new york and i'm proud of
the protests
[Music]
there is damage everywhere you look
honestly it looks like a war zone
heartwarming to see so many people turn
out peacefully
st john's church is on fire did you just
about this man
that that's a myth
i hope someone burns down your whole
precinct with all you all inside
uh it is not generally speaking
[Music]
you claim that it's wrong to object to
the certification of election results
you along with your allies in the media
attempted to cancel and censor
members of this chamber who voiced
concerns and objected to certification
manager raskin you'd been in congress
only three days
when you objected in 2017. it's one of
the first things you did when you got
here
i have an objection because 10 of the 29
electoral votes cast by florida were
cast by electors not lawfully
certified is the objection in writing
and
signed not only by the member of the
house of representatives but also by a
senator
it is in writing mr president is it
signed by a senator not as of yes mr
president in that case the objection
cannot be
entertained mr president i object to the
certificate from the state of georgia on
the grounds that the electoral vote
no debate there's no debate can i object
to a certificate
uh from the state of north carolina
based on violations
i object because people are horrified by
the overwhelming
section 18 title three the united states
code prohibits debate
um i object objected to the counting of
the electoral
votes of the state of ohio i object to
the certificate from the state of
alabama the electors were not lawfully
certified
i object to the 15 votes from the state
of north carolina because of the massive
voter suppression and the closing of
voting
polling boosters
i have an objection to the electoral
votes the objection is in writing and i
don't care that it is not it is not
signed by a member
of the senate i do not wish to debate
i wish to ask is there one united states
senator
who will join me in this letter there is
no debate
the objection is is signed by a member
of the house but not yet by a member of
the senate
it is over
[Applause]
and when the house managers realize that
the president's actual words could not
have incited the riot
as you alleged in your article of
impeachment you attempted to pivot
you said that raising the issue of
election security and casting doubt on
the propriety of our elections
was dangerous one of the house managers
mr sicilian told you that this is not
about the words mr trump used
in isolation rather it is about
the big lie the claim that the election
was stolen
the house managers told you that it's
the big lie that incited the riot
and that the big lie was president
trump's claim
that the election was not a fair
election or that the election was stolen
claiming an election was stolen you were
told
are words that are insightful to a
candidate's followers
and cause people to respond violently
claiming an election was stolen or not
legitimate
is something that a candidate should
never do because he or she knows or
should know
that such a claim and such words can
actually incite
violent insurrection you were told well
it seems that the house manager's
position
must be actually a bit narrower than
that the house manager's position really
is that
when republican candidates for office
claim an election is stolen
or that the winner is illegitimate it
constitutes inciting an insurrection
and the candidate should know it but
democratic party candidates for public
elective office
are perfectly entitled to claim the
election was stolen or that the winner
is illegitimate
or to make any other outrageous claim
they can it is their absolute right to
do so
and it is their absolute right to do so
irrespective of whether there's any
evidence to support the claim
democratic candidates can claim that an
election was stolen because of
russian collusion or without any
explanation at all
and that is perfectly okay and is in no
way
incitement to an insurrection and
somehow
when democratic candidates publicly
decry an election
as stolen or illegitimate it's never
a big lie you've been doing it for years
but can you imagine telling your
supporters
that the only way you could possibly
lose is if an american election
was rigged and stolen from you
and ask yourself whether you've ever
seen
anyone at any level of government
make the same claim about their own
election if stacey abrams doesn't win in
georgia they stole it it's clear
it's clear and i would say i say that
publicly it's clear
you can run the best campaign you can
even become the nominee
and you can have the election stolen
from you he knows he's an illegitimate
president
he knows he knows that there were
a bunch of different reasons why the
election turned out the way it did
votes remain to be counted there are
voices that were waiting to be heard
and i will not concede respect and i
respect where you're coming from and i
respect the
the issues that you're raising you're
not answering the question do you think
you
can
you know you're not using the word
legitimate
there are still legitimate concerns over
the integrity of our elections
and of ensuring the principle of one
person
one vote i agree with tens of millions
of americans
who are very worried that when they cast
the ballot
on an electronic voting machine that
there is
no paper trail to record that vote
but constantly shifting vote tallies in
ohio
and malfunctioning electronic machines
which may not have paper receipts have
led to additional loss of confidence by
the public
this is their only opportunity to have
this debate
while the country is listening and it is
appropriate to do so
house manager castro no longer has to
try to imagine it
thanks to the distinguished senator and
others it didn't have to be this way
the democrats promised unity they
promised to deliver the very coveted
relief in the form of two thousand
dollars
stimulus checks the president trump
called for
they should have listened to their own
words of the past
i leave you with the wise words of
congressman jerry nadler
the effect of impeachment is to overturn
the popular will of the voters
we must not overturn an election and
remove a president from office
except to defend our system of
government or our constitutional
liberties
against the dire threat and we must not
do so without an overwhelming consensus
of the american people
there must never be a narrowly voted
impeachment
or an impeachment supported by one of
our major political parties
and opposed by the other such an
impeachment will produce the
divisiveness and bitterness in our
politics for years to come
and will call into question the very
legitimacy of our political institutions
the american people have heard the
allegations against the president
and they overwhelmingly oppose
impeaching him they elected president
clinton
they still support him we have no right
to overturn the considered judgment
of the american people mr speaker
the case against the president has not
been made there is far from sufficient
evidence
to support the allegations and the
allegations
even if proven true do not rise to the
level of impeachable offenses
mr speaker this is clearly a partisan
railroad job
the same people who today tell us we
must impeach the president for lying
under oath
almost to a person voted last year to
re-elect the speaker who had just
admitted lying to congress
in an official proceeding the american
people are watching and they will not
forget
you may have the votes you may have the
muscle
but you do not have the legitimacy of a
national consensus
or of a constitutional imperative this
partisan coup d'etat
will go down in infamy in the history of
this nation
thank you mr speaker i yield back the
balance of my time
thank you
so
good afternoon again senators
mr president
there are two fundamental questions for
purposes of this
free speech analysis first
does the first amendment to the
constitution apply
in this chamber to these impeachment
proceedings
second if it does do the words spoken by
mr trump at the ellipse on january 6
meet the definition of constitutional
incitement
so as to void the protections afforded
by the first amendment
i will explain why the answers to both
of these questions
must be a resounding yes
the constitution in the first amendment
must
certainly apply to these impeachment
proceedings and mr trump's speech
deserves full protection under the first
amendment
but before getting into the legal
analysis some preliminary observations
about the house manager's
case should be made
first this case unfortunately
is about political hatred it has become
very clear that the house
democrats hate donald trump
this type of political hatred has no
place in our political institutions
and certainly no place in the law
this hatred has led the house managers
to manipulate and selectively edit
mr trump's speech to make it falsely
appear
that he sought to incite the crowd to
violently attack the capital
he didn't and we will show you why
the hatred has also led the house
managers to make some
astounding legal arguments they
astoundingly urge you to
disregard your oath by ignoring
the first amendment of the constitution
they also ignore landmark binding
united states supreme court cases
precedents wood and bond
both of which unequivocally hold that
elected officials
have core first amendment rights to
engage in the exact
type of political speech which mr trump
engaged in
i was shocked the house managers not
only spent a mere
three pages on the first amendment
analysis
in their trial memo but yesterday they
spent a three
a mere 10 minutes at the end of their
case
as a throwaway what we have read and
what we have heard
is devoid of any constitutional analysis
for less than what i would expect from a
first year law student
they left out landmark cases
total dishonesty
and finally hatred is at the heart of
the house
manager's frivolous attempts to blame
donald trump for the criminal acts
of the rioters based on double-here
state
hearsay statements of fringe right-wing
groups based on no real evidence other
than rank
speculation hatred is a dangerous thing
we all have to work to overcome it
hatred should have no place in this
chamber
in these proceedings
the second observation the senate is
presented with an extraordinary
task sitting in judgment of a former
president's words
in a speech that he gave at a political
event
the house managers accused mr trump of
using his words to incite
the horrific events at the capitol on
january 6.
but yesterday they gave you a new and
novel standard of incitement
with an element of foreseeability a
negligence concept
they cite zero case law they made it up
this task of applying a completely
made-up
legal standard of incitement to an
impeachment proceeding
is truly an unprecedented task for the
senate
and that is something the senate must
seriously consider
when deciding the issue
do you want to create a precedent
where the senate will be tasked with
sitting in judgment
as to the meaning and implied intent of
a president's words
or words of any elected official
will that allow and maybe encourage a
majority party
to weaponize the awesome power of
impeachment against the minority to
suppress
a point of view
will the senate then have to deal with
constant
articles of impeachment by a majority
party
accusing minority presidents or other
elected officials of so-called
insightful or false speeches
you can see where this would lead
sadly we have all seen the political
rhetoric get ratched up over the last
few years
we've all been witnesses too many
incinerate incendiary
words by our officials at political
events
broadcast over the media internet
in each of those instances will there
now be senate
impeachment hearings
one last observation
we agree with the house managers context
does indeed matter
the inflammatory rhetoric from our
elected officials must be considered as
part of the larger
context of mr trump's speech at the
ellipse on january
6th the inflammatory language from both
sides of the aisle has been alarming
frankly
but this political discourse must be
considered as part of these proceedings
to contextualize mr trump's words
we have some video to play that
highlights some of what i'm talking
about
i prefaced this video by noting i am not
showing you this video as some excuse
for mr trump's speech this is not about
this is not what about ism
i am showing you this to make the point
that
all political speech must be protected
i i just don't even know why there
aren't uprisings all over the country
maybe there will be there needs to be
unrest in the streets for as long as
there is unrest in our lives
you got to be ready to throw a punch you
have to be ready to throw a punch
donald trump i think you need to go back
and punch him in the face
that i thought he should have punched
him in the face i feel like punching him
i'd like to take him behind the gym if i
were in high school we were in high
school i'd take him behind the gym and
beat the hell out of him
no i wish you're in high school i could
take him behind the gym i will
go and take trump out tonight take him
out now dude
when was the last time an actor
assassinated a president
they're still going to have to go out
and put a bullet in donald trump show me
where it says that protests are supposed
to be polite
and peaceful
[Music]
i have thought an awful lot about
blowing up the white house
please get up in the face of some
congresspeople
people will do what they do i want to
tell you for such
i want to tell you kavanaugh you have
released the whirlwind
and you will pay the price we're gonna
go in there
this is just a warning to you trumpers
be careful
walk lightly and for those of you
who are soldiers make them pay
if you had to be stuck in an elevator
with either president trump mike pence
or jeff sessions who would it be
does one of us have to come out alive
again i did not show you their robust
speech
to excuse or balance out the speech of
my client
for i need not
i showed you the video because in this
political forum
all robust speech should be protected
and it should be protected evenly for
all of us
as a brief aside we should all reflect
and acknowledge the rhetoric
has gotten to be too much and over the
top
it is grading on the collective
well-being of
the body public the citizens
most would like it to stop
but the point is when you see speech
such as this
you have to apply the first amendment
evenly
blindly she is blind
lady justice
question one does the first amendment
apply
to this chamber in these proceedings
the house manager's position as stated
in their trial brief
is and i quote
the first amendment does not apply at
all to an impeachment proceeding that's
their position
this is plainly wrong
the text of the first amendment
expressly restricts congress from
regulating speech
it says congress shall make no law
respecting an establishment of religion
or prohibiting the free exercise thereof
or abridging the freedom of speech
or of the press or the right of the
people
peaceably to assemble and to petition
the government for a redress
of grievances to ignore the constitution
would be contrary to the oath
of office of a united states senator
i do solemnly swear or affirm that i
will support
and defend the constitution of the
united states
against all enemies
and domestic that i will bear true
faith and allegiance to the same
well you all know the rest
no the senate cannot ignore the first
amendment the constitution itself
limits the bill the ability of the house
to
impeach to unlimited items such as high
crimes and misdemeanors
the position advanced by the house
managers is essentially
an unlimited impeachment standard
without
constitutional guard rails unmoored
to any specific legal test other than
the unbridled
discretion of congress
this is distinctly not the intent of the
framers
the framers were aware of the danger of
any impeachment process that would make
the president the mere creature of the
legislature
a quote directly from the framers while
debating
the impeachment process on the floor
of the constitutional convention of 1787
the framers were fearful that any
impeachment process that gave
congress full discretion on the standard
for
impeachment would constitute nothing
less
than a violation quote a violation of
the final
fundamental principle of good government
one founding father james wilson wrote
extensively on the impeachment process
mr wilson was a renowned legal scholar
at the time
a law professor at the university of
pennsylvania
in philadelphia he was a major force in
drafting and adopting
the constitution in 1787.
he served as one of the first supreme
one of the first
six supreme court justices 1789
set he was appointed by president
george washington in fact
wilson taught the first course on the
new constitution
to president washington and his cabinet
the first in the nation's history in
philadelphia
at the university of pennsylvania in
1789.
wilson in his law lectures the first of
their kind
under the constitution plainly states
that the senate may not
ignore the constitution in impeachment
proceedings
he states that lawful and constitutional
conduct
may not be used
as an impeachable offense let me say
that again
he states that lawful and constitutional
conduct may not be used as an
impeachable offense
read along with me
the doctrine of impeachments is of high
import
in the constitutions of free states
on one hand the most powerful magistrate
should be amenable
to the law on the other hand
elevated characters should not be
sacrificed merely
on account of their elevation
no one should be secure while he
violates the constitution and the laws
everyone should be secure
while he observes them
to be clear james wilson is saying that
the constitution
does indeed apply when judging whether
to convict
an official by impeachment if the
complaint of conduct is constitutional
it cannot be impeachable
are we to ignore the words and teachings
of james wilson the house manager surely
wants you to
the house managers have made several
references
to this letter signed by 140
partisan law professors calling mr
trump's
first amendment defense legally
frivolous
this is really an outrageous attempt to
intimidate
mr trump's lawyers whenever a lawyer
advances a truly frivolous argument they
may violate
professional ethical rules and could be
subject to
discipline this letter is a direct
threat to my law license my career
and my family's financial well-being
these law professors should be ashamed
of themselves and so should the house
managers how dare you do you really
hate donald trump so much that you're
willing to destroy
good hard-working people's lives
people that are only doing their jobs
and frankly
as counsel for an accused fulfilling a
constitutional role
it's astounding really i'm a citizen
not a politician
i know these first amendment arguments
are not anywhere close
to frivolous they are completely
meritorious
interestingly the law professor's letter
was issued on february
5th three days before we even filed
our legal brief in this matter
and they ignored landmark bed
rock supreme court cases directly
addressing this issue
in our brief we have a direct quote from
james wilson
the founding father supporting our
position the direct quote was documented
in the founding fathers original legal
papers
on the subject he was the primary
draftsman of the constitution who taught
the new constitution of
president washington he says so long as
acts of elected officials like mr trump
are constitutionally protected
he should not be impeached we have
landmark u.s supreme court decisions
wood and bonds which i'll explain in
detail
supporting our position all of this the
house managers
and the partisan law professors
completely
and misleadingly ignore
frivolous hardly
the letter is a bully tactic and i think
evidence is the house managers know
they have a problem with the first
amendment defense
on the merits so they're resorting to
such
tactics the house manager's suggestion
that the first amendment does not apply
to this impeachment
process is completely untenable
ignoring the first amendment would
conflict with the senator's oath of
office
it would also conflict with well settled
supreme court precedent
and ignored the intent of the framers of
the constitution
such as james wilson above
all else ignoring the constitution
would adopt the new raskin
common sense doctrine we heard yesterday
eroding hundreds of years of first
amendment protections
we are here under the constitution it is
illogical what the house
managers say the constitution does apply
to this constitutional impeachment
process
it's double talk nonsense
illogical if the house managers had
their way they would ignore all of the
constitution
does that include the sixth amendment
the right to counsel they would have mr
trump sitting here without lawyers
and who would be next it could be anyone
what are you or one of you
you must reject this invitation to
ignore the first amendment
it is anti-american and would set
dangerous
precedent forever
the law has developed over the years to
clearly establish elected officials
have the right to engage in protected
speech
mr trump is not just a guy on the street
or a guy at a bar or a fire chief or a
police officer there were a few of them
in there
all analogies given by the house
managers
these sideways analogies are wrong
mr trump was an elected official and
there is an entire body of law
supreme court landmark cases supporting
the conclusion
that mr trump actually has enhanced
free speech rights because he is an
elected official
these cases are ignored by the house
managers
and the law professors
and that too is total intellectual
dishonesty
the supreme court has long held that the
first amendment's right to freedom of
speech protects elected officials
two important on-point decisions from
the supreme court
wood versus georgia and bond versus
floyd
expressly contradict the house manager's
position
the house managers do not even cite
those cases in their brief they barely
acknowledged them
in their reply and they were
mum on them yesterday
in wood versus georgia the supreme court
addressed a case involving a sitting
sheriff
whose reelection was being investigated
by a grand jury
and paneled by a judge based on
allegations
of irregular negro block
voting it was in the 60s the sheriff
spoke publicly
in multiple press releases calling the
grand jury investigations
racist illegitimate and an attempt to
intimidate voters
he even urged the grand jurors on how to
decide the issues
and not let its high office be a party
to any
political attempt to intimidate voters
the sheriff viewed the grand jury as
challenging
the legitimacy of his election
the sheriff even sent a letter to the
grand jurors
with these allegations which is an
extraordinary step since
laws in most states including georgia
prohibit attempts to influence or
intimidate jurors
the sheriff was charged and convicted of
contempt of court
and obstruction of the grand jury
but the supreme court in a decision
written by justice brennan reversed
the court held that the first amendment
protected an elected
public official's speech because the
voting controversy
directly affected the sheriff's
political career
g-29 the petitioner was an elected
official
and had read with me please everybody
the petitioner was an elected official
and had the right to enter the field
of political controversy particularly
where his political life was at stake
the role that elected officials play in
our society
makes it all the more imperative
that they be allowed freely to express
themselves
on matters of current public importance
wood thus stands for the proposition
that a difference of political opinion
expressed in the speech
on an issue of voting irregularity
cannot be punishable where all that was
done was to encourage investigation
and peaceful political speech
just like mr trump has done here
the legal scholars call that directly
on point a second case
bond versus floyd involved a state
legislature
punishing an elected official for
protected political speech
bond is particularly instructive here
too
in bond the supreme court squarely
addressed the question of an elected
official's
punishment by a legislature for
statements alleged to have incited
public violation of the law
the burning of draft cards the court
unequivocally rejected the idea advanced
here by the house managers
that an elected official is entitled to
no protection
under the first amendment the supreme
court held
that the georgia house of
representatives was
in fact forbidden by the first amendment
from punishing bond by not ceding them
for advocating against the policy of the
united states
there are three fundamental holdings
in bond one
the manifest function of the first
amendment in a representative government
requires that legislators be given the
widest
latitude to express their views on
issues of policy
two just as erroneous statements must be
protected to give freedom
of expression the breathing space it
needs to survive
so statements criticizing public policy
and the implementation
of it must be similarly protected
third holding legislators have an
obligation to take positions on
controversial political questions so
that their constituents can be fully
informed by them
and be better able to assess their
qualifications please read along with me
their qualifications for office also
so they may be represented in
governmental debates
by the person they have elected to
represent them
mr trump enjoys this same first
amendment protection
from congress the first amendment's
protections guarantee
free speech addressing the electoral
integrity issues
essential to his career that mr trump
has consistently advocated
the house managers argue that the first
amendment and i quote
does not shield public officials who
occupy
sensitive policy-making positions from
adverse actions when their speech
undermines
important governmental interests
that is flat wrong they are
in essence attempting to treat mr trump
as their employee this is not the law
under wood and bond mr trump
was elected by the people he is an
elected official the supreme court says
elected officials must have the right
to freely engage in public speech
indeed the supreme court expressly
rejected the house manager's
argument and would versus georgia
holding that the sheriff was not a civil
servant
but elected an elected official
who had core first amendment rights
which could not be restricted
that's wood v georgia page 395
footnote 21.
the house managers do not mention wood
or bond in the trial brief or
anywhere else why
why not because it does not fit their
narrative
or their story they want to punish mr
trump
for engaging in constitutionally
protected
free speech and they do not want you to
consider the issue
but you must question
two does mr trump's speech deserve
protection
under the first amendment
there is no doubt mr trump engaged in
constitutionally protected political
speech
that the house has improperly
characterized as
incitement of insurrection the fatal
flaw of the house's argument
is that it seeks to meet out
governmental punishment
impeachment based on first amendment
political speech
speech for political purposes is the
kind of activity
to which the first amendment offers its
strongest
protection these are bedrock principles
recognized by our supreme court
for decades
the court has stated in no uncertain
terms the importance of these principles
toward democratic principles
the general proposition that freedom of
expression
upon public questions is secured by the
first amendment
has long been settled by our decisions
the constitutional safeguard we have
said
was fashioned to assure unfettered
interchange of ideas for the bringing
about of political
and social changes desired by the people
new york times v sullivan
our first amendment decisions have
created a rough
hierarchy in the constitutional
protection of speech
core political speeches occupy the
highest
most protected position
even political speech that may incite
unlawful conduct
is protected from the reach of
government punishment
the court has said every idea is an
incitement and if speech may be
suppressed
when it might inspire someone to act
unlawfully
then there is no limit to the state's
sensorial power
the government may not prohibit speech
because it increases the chances of an
unlawful act will be completed
committed at some indefinite time in the
future
the house manager showed you a series of
tweets
going all the way back to 2015
in an effort to prove incitement
all of that evidence is totally
irrelevant
under the constitutional definition
of incitement
brandenburg versus ohio is really the
landmark case on the issue of incitement
speech
half of the case was mentioned yesterday
in the brandenburg v
ohio case another landmark the court
held the government
may only the government may only
suppress
speech for advocating the use of force
or a violation of law
if such advocacy is directed to inciting
or producing eminent lawless action
and is likely to incite or produce such
action the brandenburg holding
has been interpreted as having three
basic
prongs to determine if speech
meet the definition of incitement
the brandenburg test precludes speech
from being sanctioned as incitement to a
riot
unless this one
the speech explicitly or implicitly
encouraged use
of violence or lawless action
two the speaker intends that his speech
will result
in use of violence or lawless action
and three the imminent use of violence
or lawless action
is likely is the likely result
of the speech the house managers cannot
get past the first
prong of the brandenburg test
they have not and cannot
prove mr trump explicitly
or implicitly encourage use of violence
or lawless action period
brandenburg requires a close examination
of the words
themselves the words are either
important or they're not
the house managers admitted that the
incitement issue
is not about the words
why not because on the face of it
mr trump's words are no different than
the
figurative speech used by every one of
the senators
assembled here today if it is not about
the words
but about the big lie of a stolen
election
then why isn't house manager raskin
guilty
since he tried to overturn the 2016
election the more the house managers
speak the more hypocrisy
gets revealed
hypocrisy
even though they say it's not about the
words
the law under brandenburg requires a
close analysis
of the words to determine incitement
so we need to look at those words
mr trump did the opposite of advocating
for lawless action the opposite
he expressly advocated for peaceful
action
at the save america rally he explicitly
stated these are the words
i know that everyone here will soon be
marching over to the capitol
building to peacefully and patriotically
make your voices heard
to peacefully and patriotically
make your voices heard
that is how this president has spoken
for
years when he condemns violence
lawlessness and rioters
the house managers have played
manipulated
selectively edited parts of mr trump's
speech they focus
heavily on the word fight
the president used the word fight
20 times in his speech
they picked only two
why why not the other 18
because they don't tell the story the
way
they want to tell it
here are all of them listen to the
context
and rudy you did a great job
he's got guts you know what he's got
guts unlike a lot of people in the
republican party
he's got guts he fights he fights ed
i'll tell you thank you very much john
fantastic job i watched
that's a tough act to follow those two
there's so many weak republicans and
we have great ones jim jordan and some
of these guys they're out there fighting
the house guys are fighting
but it's uh it's incredible many of the
republicans i help
them get in i help them get elected get
rid of how do you say i want to get rid
of america first
even if you're going to do it don't talk
about it right
unbelievable what we have to go through
what we have to go through and you have
to get your people
to fight and if they don't fight we have
to primary the hell out of the ones that
don't fight
you primarium we're gonna we're gonna
let you know who they are
i can already tell you frankly
republicans are constantly fighting like
a boxer
with his hands tied behind his back it's
like a boxer
and we want to be so nice
we want to be so respectful of everybody
including
bad people and we're going to have to
fight much harder
and mike pence is going to have to come
through for us and if he doesn't
that will be a sad day for our country
because you're sworn to uphold
our constitution
and the accountability says if we see
somebody in there that doesn't treat our
vets well
or they steal they rob they do things
badly
we say joe you're fired get out of here
before you couldn't do that
you couldn't do that before so we've
taken care of things we've done things
like nobody's ever thought
possible and that's part of the reason
that
many people don't like us because we've
done too much
but we've done it quickly and we were
going to sit home and watch a big
victory and everybody had us down for a
victory it was going to be great
and now we're out here fighting i said
to somebody i was going to take a few
days
and relax after our big electoral
victory
10 o'clock it was over the american
people do not believe
the corrupt fake news anymore they have
ruined their reputation
but you know it used to be that they'd
argue with me i'd fight so i'd fight
they'd fight i'd fight that fight pop-up
you'd believe me you'd believe them
somebody comes out you know
they had their point of view i had my
point of view but you'd have an argument
now what they do is they go silent
it's called suppression and that's what
happens
in a communist country that's what they
do they suppress
you don't fight with them anymore unless
it's a bad serve they have a little bad
story about me they make it ten times
worse and it's a major headline
but hunter biden they don't talk about
him what happened to hunter where's
hunter
with your help over the last four years
we built the greatest political movement
in the history of our country and nobody
even challenges that
i say that over and over and i never get
challenged by the fake news
and they challenge almost everything we
say but our fight against the big donors
big media big tech and others
is just getting started this is the
greatest in history there's never been a
movement like that
our brightest days are before us
our greatest achievements still wait i
think one of our great achievements
will be election security because nobody
until i came along
had any idea how corrupt our elections
were
and again most people would stand there
at nine o'clock
in the evening and say i want to thank
you very much
and they go off to some other life but i
said
something's wrong here something's
really wrong can't have happened
and we fight we fight like hell and if
you don't fight like hell
you're not going to have a country
anymore our exciting adventures and
boldest endeavors
have not yet begun my fellow americans
for our movement
for our children and for our beloved
country
and i say this despite all that's
happened
the best is yet to come
a boxer fighting with his hand tied
behind his back
members of congress fighting rudy being
rudy
these are the metaphorical rhetorical
uses of the word
fight we all know that right
suddenly the word fight is off limits
sparrows the hypocrisy and false
indignation
it's a term used over and over and over
again by politicians on both sides of
the aisle
and of course the democrat house
managers know that the word
fight has been used figuratively in
political speech
forever but don't take it from me
it's best to listen to them our mission
is to fight
our job is to fight we are in a we are
in a fight we are
in a fight democrats are fighting as
hard as we can democrats are standing up
to fight
we know how to fight we like a good
fight
democrats are gonna fight like hell we
fight like hell
i'm gonna fight like hell i will fight
like hell we're gonna fight like hell
i'm gonna fight like hell
i might help i will fight like hell we
have to fight like hell
i and i know many other senators and
members of the house will fight like
hell
we are gonna fight like hell we're gonna
fight
like how i'll fight like hell and we
just have to fight
we're gonna fight we are gonna fight
we're gonna fight we're gonna
fight because you'll fight to fight
political
revolution that means that millions
millions
millions millions i've got to stand up
and
fight and fight and fight stand up
and fight back to fight and continue to
fight
once again fight back in the fight we're
fighting that
my fight to fight an administration you
don't get what you don't
fight for we'll also fight him and
challenge him in every way that we can
fight in congress fight in the courts
fight in the streets in the congress
in the courts and in the streets there's
the fight there's the fight there's the
fight and then there's the fight
to defend we're eager to take on this
fight the american people
are going to have to fight get in this
fight get in this fight around the clock
fighting
we've got to keep fighting and keep
focused we will
fight when we must fight we've been
fighting
and we need to fight but we also need to
fight there's always going to be an
uphill fight
this is going to be a fight we always
must fight
we're in the fight of our lives we're
going to be into the fight of our lives
this is the fight of our life the fight
of their lives we are
in this fight for our lives we cannot
ever give up on fighting
hypocrisy
the reality is mr trump was not
in any way shape or form
instructing these people to fight or to
use
physical violence what he was
instructing them to do
was to challenge their opponents in
primary elections
to push for sweeping election reforms
to hold big tech responsible
all customary and legal ways to petition
your government for redress of
grievances
which of course is also protected
constitutional speech
but the house managers don't want you to
focus on those things
because again it does not fit their
story
in the end i leave you with this
quote from benjamin franklin
freedom of speech is a principle pillar
of a free government when this support
is taken away the constitution
of a free society is dissolved
and tyranny is erected
on its ruins thank you
mr president the majority leader i ask
unanimous consent the senate recess for
a 15-minute break
so
blackboard
what are you listening
okay
foreign
i don't want it
all right
uh
uh
oh
oh
i mean
how are ya
okay
oh
here's the context
um
[Music]
the senate will be said it will be an
order
senators will take their seats
who seeks recognition
mr castro is recognized
mr president it's clear of the senate
good afternoon
it has been my great privilege over the
past
couple of weeks to lead this
outstanding team of lawyers and
dedicated professionals in the defense
of the 45th president of the united
states
one of the most difficult things in
leading such a talented group is
deciding who's responsible for what
and the strategy and the order in which
we will present
our evidence
and you have heard from mr van der veen
and mr sean
on the importance of the first amendment
and the importance of
due process of law
and because i had
the opportunity to set out the schedule
i decided that i would take
the last substantive part of the case
for myself
you can take that two ways the first
perhaps is the best and that would be
that it's almost over
the second is that perhaps you have to
wait another hour
for it to be over
the reason why i chose this section and
believe me
it was a very difficult decision to make
because i thought that the other
arguments presented by mr shawn and mr
van der veen were outstandingly
researched
thoroughly vetted and wonderfully
and articulately presented by them
but the critical issue in this case
is the very narrow issue
that is charged against the 45th
president
and that issue is did the 45th president
engage
in incitement of they continue to say
insurrection
clearly there was no insurrection
insurrection is a term of artists
defined in the law it involves taking
over a country
a shadow government taking the tv
stations over
and having some plan on what you're
going to do when you finally
take power clearly this is not that
what our colleagues here across the
aisle meant
is incitement to violence
to riot so the word incitement is the
critical
case and the critical issue in the case
now the first time that you heard from
us
i told you that you would never hear
from our side
that what happened on january 6th was
anything other than
horrific and that the 45th president of
the united states
and his lawyers and his entire team
adamantly denounce that violence
by those criminals that occurred in this
very chamber
this very building
there was a reason why we started
our presentation back on tuesday
in that way because
i did not want the senators to consider
that there was any challenge to that
particular
fact and yet
the house managers knowing it was not in
contested at all chose to spend
14 plus hours showing you pictures
of how horrific the attack on the united
states capital was
they spent no time at all
in connecting legally
the attack on the capital to the
45th president of the united states
which is the
only question that needs to be answered
is was donald trump responsible for
inciting the violence
that came to this building
on january 6th
now by any
measure president trump
is the most pro-police anti-mob rule
president this country has ever seen
his real supporters know this
he made it clear throughout his
presidency
he made it clear during the violence
this past summer
he made it clear on january 6th
but politics changes things
politics has created and interposed
an element that should not be here
it has interposed the element of hatred
and the political world changes when
hatred
becomes part of the dynamic
as we wrote in our answer
to the original charging document
and i hope that this is a phrase that
lives on
long after we are all departed
and that i hope someday this becomes the
mantra
by which all of us
operate who work for the benefit of the
public
that political hatred has no place
in the american justice system and most
certainly no place in the congress
of the united states
to illustrate the contrast that i am
speaking of
we have a video i am your president
of law and order and an ally of all
peaceful protesters the vast majority of
of the protesting the peace
republicans stand for law and order
and we stand for justice i just don't
even know why there aren't uprisings
all over the country maybe they will be
my administration will always stand
against violence
mayhem and disorder there needs to be
unrest in the streets for as long as
there is unrest in our lives
i stand with the heroes
[Music]
together we will ensure that america is
a nation of law
and order in high school i'd take you
behind the gym and beat the hell out of
him
i think you need to go back and then
punch him in the face feel like punching
him
we just want law and order everybody
wants that
i want to tell you such i want to tell
you kavanaugh
you have released the whirlwind and you
will pay the price we want law and order
we have to have law and order
show me where it says that protests are
supposed to be polite and peaceful we
believe in safe streets secure
communities and we believe in law
and order
is there truly anyone in this chamber
who disagrees with the words as spoken
by president trump
on that video surely not
surely not
this contrast and in this context
i ask you to keep it keep that in mind
my colleagues here actually my colleague
here
mr raskin hopes that you don't
they have used selective editing and
manipulated visuals to paint a picture
far
different from this truth
make no mistake and i will repeat it now
and anytime i'm ever asked
january 6th was a terrible day for our
country
the attack on this building shocked us
all
president trump did not incite or cause
the horrific violence
that occurred on january 6 2021
they know that
we know the president did not incite the
riot because of his plain words that day
as mr van der veen elucidated on a few
moments ago
we know the president could not have
incited the riots because of the
timeline
of the events of that day we heard a
great deal from
the house manager about their
prosecutorial bona fides
and their ability to analyze evidence
apply it to statutes
use timelines and figure out what
happened based on circumstantial
evidence and direct evidence and
testimony
and and forensic analysis
i can't recall any of the house managers
who got up
that didn't make some reference to
prosecutorial bona fides
well i spent more than three decades
locking up killers and
i do know a little bit about applying
the facts to the law
we know that the president would never
have wanted such a riot to occur
because his long-standing hatred for
violent protesters
and his love for law and order is on
display worn on his sleeve
every single day that he served in the
white house
but if we're going to apply
the facts to the statue it has to be
done
systematically has to be done
with precision the way a court
would expect us to do that
let's look at the letter of the law
again mr vanderveen gave you an
overview of the brandenburg case in some
of the related cases
you notice that when mr van der veen
listed the elements that he
took verbatim or close to verbatim right
out of vandenberg
they bore no reference whatsoever to the
elements that were flashed up
by the democrat managers the other day
repeatedly
he actually used the supreme court's
case
he didn't make it up let's look at the
letter of the law
the supreme court of the united states
over 50
years ago laid out a clear test
to determine whether speech is
incitement
under that test the brandenburg versus
ohio test
there are three elements that must be
proven
beyond a reasonable doubt by a
preponderance of the evidence
whatever the senate considers suggest
beyond a reasonable doubt
first the speech in question must
explicitly or
implicitly encourage the use of violence
or lawless action the
but here the president's speech called
for peaceful protest
second the speaker must intend that
his speech will result in the use of
violence
or lawless action and again
as the as mr van der veen pointed out
the president clearly deplores
rioters and political violence and did
so
throughout his term as president and
never hesitated
to express his admiration for the men
and women
that protect this country finally
the third element under the brandenburg
test is the
imminent use of violence imminent use of
violence
in other words right then the imminent
use of violence or lawless action
must be the the likely result
of the speech the likely result of the
speech
well that argument is completely
eviscerated
by the fact that the violence was
pre-planned as confirmed by the fbi
department of justice and even the house
managers not the result of the speech at
all
several of my colleagues at the house
managers got up and
spoke about the proceeding in the house
being
like a grand jury proceeding
well i've been in grand jury proceedings
i have run grand juries
in grand jury proceedings you call
witnesses you hear
evidence you make transcripts you take
affidavits
you develop physical evidence you hear
reports from police officers
you hear forensic analysis from
scientists
in fact you invite the target of the
grand jury
to come in and testify if he or she
pleases to be heard
by the grand jury which one of those
things
happened in the house
prior to the impeachment article
i don't believe any of them happened
so the suggestion that what happened in
the house
was anything at all like a grand jury
investigating a case and preferring it
for prosecution
is complete nonsense
and if the house managers are trying to
fool you about that
you must ask yourself what else are they
trying to fool you about
let's look more closely at the
president's speech
we have mentioned this line before but
it is so critical
we need to talk about it again the
president
asked that the attendees at his rally
peacefully
make their voices heard
i know that everyone here will soon be
marching over to the capitol building
to peacefully and patriotically make
your voices heard
the managers would have you believe that
the president's supporters
usually follow his every word but in
this case
imputed some imaginary meaning to them
while ignoring his most clear
instructions
president trump said peacefully and
patriotically make your voices heard
and the house managers heard took from
that
go down to the capitol and riot
so you are supposed to put your
selves in the heads of the people who
hear peacefully and patriotically make
your voices heard
and conclude that not those words do not
mean
what the president said
more than that the president criticized
the destruction wrought by left-wing
anarchists and rioters
he told his supporters that they build
they don't destroy if this happened to
the democrats
there'd be hell all over the country
going on there'd be hell
all over the country but just remember
this you're stronger
you're smarter you've got more going
than anybody
and they try and demean everybody having
to do with us
and you're the real people you're the
people that built this nation
you're not the people that tore down our
nation
is it possible listening to those words
in
in the proper cadence without them being
edited
or the sound changed so that they're
indistinguishable or sounds as though
the crowd is right there
but listening to it as you have here
unedited by us
is it possible that president trump's
disdain
for political violence could be any
clearer
to the persons listening as he was
speaking
is it possible that his word could have
been
misunderstood i suggest to you
that is impossible
now the house manager said the president
told
the crowd quote
you have to get out your people to fight
the house manager's claim is that the
president of the united states was
telling the audience
to get each to get each other to
physically fight but that is not
what the president said
the people who should fight he said
were members of congress if they don't
fight
what the president said is what should
the
uh what should the rally attendees do
if members of congress wouldn't fight
for the
principles they held dear what were what
was it that the president
specifically told his supporters at that
rally he wanted them to do
he wanted them to support primary
challenges
now nobody in this chamber
is anxious to have a primary challenge
that is one truism i think i can say
with some certainty but that's the way
we operate in this country when the
people of a state
want to change their representatives
and their senators they use the
electoral process
president trump told his listeners that
if their members of congress won't fight
for their views
then go back home and find others that
will
that's what president trump said the
people should
who should fight were were the members
of congress
[Music]
you have to get your people
to fight he told them
you have to get your people to fight and
if they don't fight
we have to primary the hell out of the
ones that don't fight
we primary them we're gonna we're gonna
let you know who they are
i can already tell you frankly
it is pretty stark contrast when you
watch
that video isn't it when you see the
house manager
tell you and
i don't know if we're under oath here
but when i walked into this room i sure
as heck felt i was under oath
and that i was speaking not only as a
senator of the united states but before
the entire world
and with god watching and
a house manager got up here and told you
that the president of the united states
on january the 6th 2021
told the crowd that they had to go
and fight and the implication that they
wanted you to draw
was that he was sending him down to
capitol hill to go
and breach the building and trash
the very sacred halls of congress
but we now know that is not at all
anything near what the president said
what the president said was if you can't
get your members of congress to do
as you would like them to do you primary
them
that's the american way the first way
that the house managers presented and
wanted
you to conclude that's the criminal way
but what the president said was the
american way
again house managers manipulated
president trump's words i can't stand
here
and pretend to tell you that i know
every time from all those videos that
the house managers manipulated
what the president said put up
evidence that was not
with the foundation of correctness and
admissibility we expect
i can't tell you that i picked up
everyone i don't think mr van der veen
or mr schoen
or any of the others that work with us
can tell you that
but what i can tell you is that there
were an awful lot of times
and i know at least some of you were
judges in previous lives
and that and if one of the lawyers was
able to create
the impression that one side
intentionally presented false or
misleading evidence
that judge would give an instruction
called false
false is anonymous false in one thing
false in everything
in other words if they're trying to fool
you about one thing
not only might they be trying to fool
you in something else
but under that maxim of the law you may
conclude they're trying to fool you
in everything else
president trump was immediate in his
calls for calm and respect for law
enforcement
the house managers emphasized president
trump's tweet
in the 6 p.m hour where he told crowds
to
quote go home in love and peace
and remember this day what is it that
they left out
well the house
starts their recitation of what
president trump said
as far as the aftermath of when the
capital was breached
at roughly 6 pm what they don't
tell you and didn't tell you and which
you probably don't know
because i think i'm the first one to say
it in
this forum is at 238
president trump urged protesters at the
u.s capitol to quote stay
peaceful please support our capitol
police
and law enforcement they are truly on
the side of our country
stay peaceful and before we run the
graphic i just want to point out to you
president trump's speech ended at 1 11
p.m so at 2 38 p.m
by the time word reaches the president
that there's a problem down here
he's out urging people to support
the police stay peaceful support our
capitol police and law enforcement
they are on the side of the country stay
peaceful
at 3 13 p.m president trump urged
protesters at the u.s capitol to remain
peaceful
no violence remember we are the party of
law and order
respect the law and our great men and
women in blue
3 13 p.m
president trump's words couldn't have
incited the riot at the capitol
today's events make this clear let's
walk through the
actual timeline
at 11 15 a.m police security camera
videos show crowds forming
at first street near the capitol
reflecting pool
this is a full 45 minutes before
president trump
even took the stage on january 6th
let me repeat that violent criminals
were assembling at the capitol over a
mile away
almost an hour before the president
uttered a
single word on the ellipse
you did not hear that fact during the
hours
and hours of the house manager's
presentation did you
when the president spoke what did he
call for
he called for rally attendees to
peacefully and patriotically make their
voices heard
for them to walk down pennsylvania
avenue to cheer on
members of congress president trump went
on for more than an hour ending at 111.
now why is this important because of
all of the events that i am about to
describe they
all occurred before
before president trump's remarks
concluded
at 12 49 p.m the first barriers at the
u.s capitol grounds were pushed
over and the crowd entered the
restricted area
at 11 05 p.m acting defense secretary
christopher miller received
open source reports of demonstrator
movements
to the u.s capitol at 109 p.m
u.s capitol police chief steven sun
called the house and senate sergeants at
arms
telling them he wanted an emergency
declared
and he wanted the national guard called
the point given the timeline of events
the criminals at the capitol weren't
there at the ellipse to even
hear the president's words they were
more than a mile away engaged in their
pre-planned assault
on this very building this was a
pre-planned assault
make no mistake and that is a critical
fact
watch this does anyone in this chamber
honestly believe that but for the
conduct of president trump
that a charge in the article of
impeachment that that attack at the
capitol would have occurred
does anybody believe that it was not
some sort of spontaneous
decision by a bunch of quote protesters
to go up to capitol hill
and storm capitol hill this was all
planned out
how much of it was was planned how much
of this was strategized ahead
of time they are getting indications uh
some evidence that they've seen that
indicates
that there was some level of planning
there appears to be premeditation
fbi internal report the day before the
siege warning of a violent
war at the capitol fbi issued a warning
of a quote
war at the capitol the fbi warned law
enforcement agencies
about this specific attack be ready to
fight
congress needs to hear glass breaking
doors being kicked in
we developed some intelligence that the
number of individuals were planning to
travel
to the dc area with intentions to cause
violence
we immediately shared that information
and they pushed out that information
through this jttf structure was
immediately disseminated through a
written product
and briefed through our command post
operations to all levels of law
enforcement the fbi
says two pipe bombs discovered near the
capitol on january 6
were placed there the night before new
video appears to show a person suspected
of
planting tight bombs near the u.s
capitol the night before
the fbi now says the bombs were planted
the night before the capital siege
between 7 30 and 8 30 pm
they were planted the day before all
goes to the idea of
premeditation and coordination among
individuals this was a planned assault
without going after a cancer
so to answer the question of the house
manager does anybody believe that this
would have occurred
but for the speech from donald trump
i do
all of these facts make clear
the january 6 speech did not cause the
riots
the president did not cause the riots he
neither explicitly
or implicitly encouraged the use of
violence or lawless action
but in fact called for peaceful exercise
of every american's first amendment
rights
to peacefully assemble and petition
their government for redress
of grievances in other words
the brandenburg standard is not made out
the house managers admitted many facts
are unknown
even speaker pelosi admitted not knowing
the real cause of the violence
when she called for a 9 11 style
commission to examine the facts and
causes
that led to the violence
on the screen is speaker pelosi's call
for the
911 commission
let's touch now on the second absurd and
conflated allegation in the house
manager's
single article president trump's phone
call to georgia secretary of state
ben roethensberger surreptitiously
recorded by the way
included and included multiple attorneys
and others
on the call let me point out the very
obvious fact that the house managers
ignored
the private call that was made public by
others cannot really be the basis to
claim
that the president intended to incite a
riot
because he did not publicly disclose the
contents of the call
how could he have hoped to use this call
to invite his followers if he had no
intent to make the conversation public
and indeed had nothing to do with it
being secretly recorded
the house managers told you that the
president demanded that the georgia
secretary of state
quote fined just over 11 000 votes
the word find like so many others
the house managers highlighted is taken
completely
out of context and the word fine
did not come out of thin air
based on an analysis of publicly
available voter data
that the ballot rejection rate in
georgia in 2016
was approximately 6.42 percent
and even though a tremendous amount of
new first-time mail-in ballots
were included in the 2020 count
the georgia rejection rate in 2020
was a mere four-tenths of one percent
a drop off from 6.42 percent
to 0.4 percent
president trump wanted the signature
verification to be done in public
how can a request for signature
verifications to be done
in public be a basis for a charge
for inciting a riot
with that background it is clear that
president trump's comments and the use
of the word
find were solely related to his concerns
with the inexplicable dramatic drop in
georgia's ballot
rejection rates
let's examine how the word find was used
throughout that conversation
mr trump's first use of the word find
was as follows
quote we think that if you
check the signatures a real check of the
signatures going back in fulton county
you'll find at least a couple hundred
thousand of forged
signatures of people who have been
forged
and we are quite sure that's going to
happen
president trump also used find as
follows
quote now why aren't we doing signature
and why can't it be open to the public
and why can't we have professionals do
it instead of
rank amateurs who will never find
anything
and don't want to find anything they
don't want to find
you know they don't want to find
anything
someday you'll tell me the reason why
because i don't understand your
reasoning but someday you'll tell me the
reason why
but why don't you want to find
president trump echoed his previous
sentiments again in the context of
pursuing
a legitimate and robust investigation
into the lack of signature verification
for mail-in and absentee ballots
quote and why can't we have
professionals do it instead of rank
amateurs who will never find anything
and don't want to find anything they
don't want to find anything you know
they don't want to find anything
they don't want to find you know they
don't want to find anything
someday you'll tell me why because i
don't understand your reasoning but
someday you'll tell me why
but why don't you want to find we can go
through signature verification and we'll
find hundreds of thousands of signatures
and you can let us do it and the only
way you can do that
to it as you know is to go to the past
but you didn't do that in cobb county
you just looked at one page compared to
another
the only way you could do a signature
verification is to go from one that
signed
it on november whatever recently
and compare it to two years ago four
years ago
six years ago you know or even one
and you'll find that you have many
different signatures but in
fulton where they dumped ballots you
will find that you have many that
aren't even signed and that you have
many forgeries
end quote
mr trump continued to use the word fine
throughout the conversation
each and every other time in the context
of his request
that mr raffesberger undertake a
signature a review of signature
verifications
and his concerns generally with ballot
integrity
and his reported electoral deficit here
are a few
examples quote
but why wouldn't you want to find the
right
answer brad instead of keep saying
what that the numbers are right because
those numbers
are so wrong another example
quote we think that if you check the
signatures
a real check of the signatures going
back in fulton county
you'll find at least a couple hundred
thousand of forged
signatures of people who have been
forged
and we are quite sure that's going to
happen
end quote
moreover there was nothing untoward
with president trump or any other
candidate for that matter
speaking with the lead elections officer
of a state
that's why the georgia secretary of
state took
a call along with members of his team
one of whom decided to record it and
release it to the press
the only reason this conversation is
being discussed in this chamber
is because once again the media and
their democratic allies
distorted the true conversation to
mislead you
and the american public
so we have a complete
lack of evidence for the article of
impeachment presented by the house
managers
so why are we here politics
their goal is to eliminate a political
opponent
to substitute their judgment for the
will
of the voters why bother with the senate
trial of donald trump he's no longer
president he'll be out of office anyway
is it to keep him from ever running
again make sure he can never run for
office again keep him from running for
office again
donald trump would not be able to run
for office again barring him from
running for office again disqualified
from running for office
disqualify him from ever running from
office again
disqualified from running for office
again it's about
focusing that he can never run again
remove him
from ever running for office again never
be able to run for office again
to ban former president trump from
running again
if we don't impeach this president he
will get reelected
the goal is to eliminate a political
opponent to substitute
their judgment for the will of the
voters
members of the senate our country needs
to get back to work
i know that you know that but instead we
are here
the majority party promised to unify
and deliver more coveted relief but
instead
they did this we will not
take most of our time today
us of the defense in the hopes that you
will
take back these hours and use them
to get delivery
of covert relief to the american people
let us be clear this trial is about far
more
than president trump it is about
silencing and banning the speech the
majority does not
agree with it is about canceling
75 million trump voters
and criminalizing political
viewpoints that is what this trial
is really about
it's the only existential issue
before us
it asks for constitutional
cancel culture to take over
in the united states senate
are we going to allow canceling and
banning
and silencing to be sanctioned in this
body
to the democrats who view this as a
moment of opportunity
i urge you instead to look to the
principles of free expression
and free speech i hope
truly that the next time you are in the
minority
you don't find yourself in this position
to the republicans in this chamber i
ask when you are next in the majority
please resist what will be an
overwhelming temptation
to do this very same thing
to the opposing party
members of the senate this concludes the
formal defense
of the 45th president of the united
states
to the impeachment article filed by the
house of representatives
i understand that there is a procedure
in place for
questions and we await them thereafter
we will close
on behalf of president trump
mr president we yield the balance
i ask unanimous consent we take a 15
minute recess without objection the
senate will stand in recess
you